ciao ragazzi bentornati hanno una
puntata di cucina buttata qualche giorno
fa ho fatto una sorpresa luigi e ho
preparato questa cena carina nella quale
mi sono messo a fare la pasta fatta in
casa ho fatto delle stories che adesso
vi faccio vedere velocemente l'ora 320
grammi di farina ci può mettere tre
uomini ho messo uno la vedo se cidas con
secondo a farlo con una mano takhti è
mamma pazzesco cracco ciao
il terzo dai così di fila perché non ho
paura della diretta
odia lo sto scappando cecchino nino nino
ono strusciando distruggendoli un
pizzico d'amore tia abbondare fate una
palettina e la fate riposare per 30
minuti
bella e poi deve stare in un luogo
freddo io ho deciso il mio balcone ii e
tra vari commenti che ricevo in privato
su instagram
ho letto un po di senti devi provare a
fare una puntata di cucina buttato nella
quale fai la pasta fatta in casa con una
sola mano in realtà ho preso spunto da
questa idea e ho pensato invece di
renderla ancora più divertente prima di
tutto chiamando qui luigi buonasera cioè
chef invece di fare la pasta fatta in
casa a quattro mani di farla comunque a
due mani e quindi io potrò usare la
sinistra e lui potrà utilizzare
solamente la destra direi che ci siamo
possiamo partire questo punto che il
procedimento è
il grembiule no già la sinistra non so
schiocchezze quella destra
ok allora a questo punto abbiamo il
grembiule abbiamo tutto quanto iniziamo
a fare la pasta fatta in casa
nessuno si dà il 5 da solo però per fare
la pasta fatta in casa abbiamo bisogno
della farina sale e olio
molte persone tipo dell'emilia romagna
quando hanno visto che io metto un
bozzetto di orio hanno detto non si fa
ormai bisogna mettere 100 g di farina
ogni uovo e vero avete ragione ma ho
imparato a metterci sempre un pizzino di
olio mi sento che devo farlo è così
sbagliato cioè gli emiliani e romagnoli
lo sanno meglio di chiunque altro come
si fa la pasta fatta in casa
in realtà si è forse un goccino cucina
la forse perché a napoli arriva lo
stesso promettere in qualsiasi impasto
nel latte caffè pasto li prendevo in
giro ma tutti i pacchi di farina perdono
farina priori apriamola signori dei
supermercati ma perché o signori di
frumento
ma perché la farina è fatta per perdere
farina quando ladri era qua era fuori
era già messa fuori non poteva non
poteva e non uscire che faccio ha detto
di usare tutte le uova quindi c'è un
altro voto in frigo è un'altra uova il
24 è andata 600 grammi se uova mamma mia
difficoltà pensare che seppure mancino 1
c'è stato ok non pre fermo non lo
rovinare ancora di più colori ci serve
un vulcano queste dura lo reggo
tutto rispondeva potrà farcela da solo
almeno nel suo tutte le responsabilità
ma perché ti sei già preso la
responsabilità
provo con la sinistra ho buttato dentro
tutto benissimo
sì devo dire che questa qui è andata
bene ho capito ci mangeranno un po di
persone laiche tamagni tutta te pizzico
di sale
io non sono per me pizzico è tipo
diamoci una sciacquata
sembrate l'unica persona considerata da
qui un pizzico di sale
ottimo è un micro micro micro filino
d'olio ragazzi fatemi sapere se è
veramente così un abete mi apra un
dibattito olio si olio no mi sa che il
no ma chi è che ce lo mette e perché poi
solo una critica mi hanno detto che non
si può usare la forchetta per unità che
le nonne ti uccidono quindi dobbiamo
fare questo decisamente lavorare il
centro come questi piacevole
oddio sto facendo non hai fatto fidati
con la forchetta della mostra cali molto
di meno
guarda sono il grinch col palmo con vaio
noi ho paura di far casino dice così ti
sta andando dal dio esiste facendo
veramente un ottimo
ora dobbiamo lavorarci questa però con
domani dobbiamo fare tac giri da tutto
il governo la manita ovviamente nelle
nelle man dovete metterlo dell'impatto
questura aspetta aspetta
piano piano piano senza violenza che
bello sarebbe toglierci questa questo
maglione non è sponsorizzata da nessuno
perché volevamo stare perché tavoli di
questo perché i mali
dovevamo usare la forchetta ma perché ho
ascoltato il rivo era presente quando io
ho fallito non evitando cioè enrico
dietro di me ma questa roba fatta
riposare ma la scelta è quella roba
pensano per la sera mi amano
poi chiudo
chiudo vai secondo me poteva metterci a
farci l'impatto si tratta ma mai detto
bravissimi ragazzi ve lo consiglio
proprio come era per i coppia esatto
farina ragazzi non lo stiamo perdendo lo
stiamo unendo finalmente house nella
tabella quella che non è così faticoso
fatto da solo è no perché ci metti pure
tutto il peso corporeo infatti dovremmo
andarci insieme di peso corporeo un
altro che palestra io mi ritrovo braccio
alberto albergo l'eredità ci siamo
chiudiamola con questo è basta
continuare aggiunge farina non c'è più
tu sei privo di sensibilità dei ragazzi
ci ha ragione
occhio che è molle e occhio dove stiamo
a tutta questa non ci non ti avvicinare
acquistati perciò adesso musica nei
limiti non entro più di ottimo
lasciamolo riposare in un luogo fresco
una mezz'ora è passata mezz'ora la
realtà che credo sia passata pure
abbiamo fatto i cavoli nostri
abbiamo già aperto uno sportello orano
richiudiamo abbiamo messo anche la
pentola sul fuoco ma lui va inquadrata
la pentola sul fuoco e acqua in un
evento a questo punto abbiamo bisogno di
quella che secondo me sarà la nostra
sfida di oggi la macchinetta per
stendere la pasta se non ci avete a casa
gli ho messo un link qui sotto se volete
prendervela su amazon altrimenti potete
usare il mattarello oppure comprarla
supermercato a questo qui è questa è la
manovella che quindi vorrei girare su è
questo qui serve per bloccarla
se siamo ancora ok prendiamo lei agli
aerei voce la ragione farina un po
appiccicosa cioè stata colpita rimane
del macchinario medico che bello che
bello vedere tutto il giorno ti stanno
chiamando riforma che succede ora noi
con l'ombelico
dovete girare prendete la semola a
questo punto di grande muro intanto
aspettano normale questo
in realtà bisognerebbe farlo proprio
alla fine questo tipo di un bellico ma
in realtà la stiamo lo stiamo stringendo
tra le anche la canzone possono fare
[Applauso]
[Musica]
vai
[Applauso]
[Musica]
ma
è bellissima ragazzi siamo arrivati alla
fine di questo video questo qui è il
risultato che adesso molto probabilmente
mangeremo col burro perché non abbiamo
nulla con quale con di tutta questa
pasta abbiamo fatto un chilo con quelle
che sono le quantità degli ingredienti
che vi abbiamo detto io ringrazio per
aver preso parte a questa cosa ringrazio
voi per seguirci sempre iscritte via
questo canale attivate le notifiche per
non perdere ma nessun video e ci vediamo
alla prossima settimana ciao ciao
e le attese abbiamo messo sono gli
spunta tour e pesto olio formaggio che
cosa ci mancava la zucca e all'altro
l'acqua di cottura erano ansa ecco
l'altra metà non è roba non si no
comunque assicura non è quella di bakwa
lui da happenning regalo da penn
ingrediente questo sento il pesto più
rifiuti sto video non è chiusa